Ang konsepto ng fundamentalismo ay mahalagang naka-ugnay sa
konsepto ng pagsukat sa quantum mechanics
bago pa man mabuo ang quantum mechanics
alam na ng mga siyentipiko
na kung mayroon kang sistema na nasa isang estado
na tiyak ang estado nito
at susukat ka dito, makakakuha ka ng
isang tiyak na resulta
sa quantum mechanics, hindi na ganoon — pwede kang magkaroon ng
sistema na nasa maayos at tiyak na estado
pero kapag gumawa ka ng ilang partikular na
pagsukat dito, pwede kang makakuha ng random na resulta
para mas maipaliwanag ko ang konseptong iyon, mas mainam na
dalhin ko ang konsepto ng superposition
ang superposition ay isang konsepto na hindi eksklusibo sa quantum mechanics
ito ay nakabatay sa linear na kombinasyon ng mga estado
ng iba't ibang linear na kombinasyon ng mga estado nang
sabay-sabay, at pwede mong isipin ito
bilang halimbawa isang radio wave na nagdadala ng
maraming iba't ibang frequency — wala namang
quantum na kinakailangan para diyan
ang nagbibigay ng quantum na kahulugan sa superposition ay ang katotohanan
ng pagsukat sa sistema
kaya ipapakita ko ito sa pamamagitan ng isang halimbawa
isipin mo na mayroon kang sistema ng mga arrow
at inihanda mo ang sistema
para lahat ng mga arrow ay nakaturo sa kaliwa
at pagkatapos ay pupunta ka at
itatanong sa sistema: ikaw ba ay pataas o pababa?
at dahil ang arrow na nakaturo sa kaliwa ay pwedeng
ipahayag o ilarawan
bilang superposition sa pagitan ng
pataas at pababa, makakakuha ka ng
resulta na limampung porsyento pataas
at limampung porsyento pababa kapag tinanong mo kung pataas ba
makukuha mo ang resultang iyon mula sa sistema
at pagkatapos ay pwede kang mag-ihanda ng
ibang estado ng sistema kung saan kalahati
ay nakaturo pataas at kalahati ay nakaturo
pababa, at tinanong mo ang parehong tanong
at makukuha mo ang parehong resulta
dalawa itong napaka-ibang sistema
pero nakuha mo ang parehong impormasyon
mula sa parehong uri ng pagsukat
paano mo malalaman kung ano ang pagkakaiba? Ang
mga sistema ay napaka-iba
dahil sa unang kaso, inihanda mo ang sistema sa isang
purong estado — may isang tanong na pwede mong
itanong sa sistema na magbibigay sa iyo ng deterministikong
resulta, at ang tanong na iyon ay: kaliwa ka ba o kanan?
sasabihin nito sa iyo na isang daang porsyento: kaliwa
sa ikalawang kaso, wala nang tanong na pwede mong
itanong na magbibigay sa iyo ng isang daang porsyentong resulta
dahil ito ay isang halo
kaya kung tinanong mo: kaliwa o kanan?
magiging random dahil kalahati ay pataas
at kalahati ay pababa. Kung tinanong mo: pataas o pababa?
ganoon din — magiging limampung porsyento rin
paano ito nag-uugnay sa quantum randomness?
Pwede mong isipin ito bilang
katulad ng paghahagis ng barya — magiging heads o tails
pero hindi ito katulad ng paghahagis ng barya
dahil kapag naghagis ka ng barya,
ang tanging dahilan kung bakit hindi mo alam ang resulta
ay dahil hindi mo alam ang
lakas na ginamit mo sa paghagis, ang anggulo, ang momentum,
ang kondisyon ng paligid
at iba pa — kaya kung alam mo ang lahat ng mga
variable na iyon, mahuhulaan mo kung heads o tails
mga variable na nakatago sa tagamasid
at sa loob ng maraming taon, akala ng mga siyentipiko na may
katulad na mga variable sa quantum mechanics na
nagpapakita lang bilang randomness
at hindi iyon naging malinaw hanggang sa
seminal na gawa ni John Bell noong dekada sitenta na talagang
naipakita na hindi ganoon ang kaso
at ngayon, bawat pisiko
ay kinikilala na walang nakatagong
variable na teorya na tugma sa quantum mechanics
kaya totoo nga na kapag sinukat mo ang isang sistema,
inihahayag ng kalikasan ang resulta nang
gaano man kalaon kong pag-isipan iyon,
sasabihin ko pa rin na kamangha-mangha iyon